we're excited to announce this morning
that our first book note to self
inspiring words from inspiring people is
now on sale over the years we've asked
politicians actors veteran singers
athletes and even an astronaut to write
to their younger selves they've
reflected on the defining moments and
lessons learned in their lives this
morning we'll hear from Heather
Duckworth of Tampa Florida she was
chosen after we asked you the viewer to
submit your own letters we received
submissions from 49 states Washington DC
Puerto Rico and Canada and we want you
to know we read every single one of your
letters Heather's story of strength and
resiliency stood out dear younger you
look at you so young and innocent I wish
I could keep you like this always
you will marry your childhood friend the
one you have known your whole life
kissing is toddlers while your parents
were stationed together in the military
the one who really used to annoy you but
don't worry this will be the best
decision you ever make he will love you
boldly through every peak in Valley of
your life you will be anxious to start a
family but unfortunately the joy of
first pregnancy will turn to
disappointment and sorrow when you have
a miscarriage this will be your first
sting of loss but remember to stay
positive because brighter days are ahead
a year later you will be blessed with a
son and a year after that you will find
yourself pregnant again you will have a
slight complication and fear the worst
you will nervously go to the doctor and
instead get the surprise of your life
you are expecting triplets you will cry
with relief as you see three tiny
heartbeats on the sonogram after a
difficult pregnancy and feeling as big
as a barn you will give birth to three
beautiful healthy baby boys
[Music]
a free heart you will love these four
boys fiercely guys and realize your
greatest gift in life is being their
mother even if they run you ragged three
years later your happy world will be
shattered when one of your triplets is
diagnosed with cancer your heart will
break
watching Jacob suffer through treatment
but he will amaze you with his courage
and fight always with a smile and he
will make you feel brave in the end your
son will pass away as six years old the
pain of his loss will be unbearable and
you will learn to walk hand in hand with
grief for the rest of your life
[Music]
it is the price of your love your family
and children will pull you out of the
trenches of grief and you will live for
Jacob and he will forever be your
inspiration for a while
you will find comfort in raising money
and awareness for pediatric cancer
research helping other families facing a
similar fight
a year later having long hope to adopt
you will fly to Guatemala with your
family to meet your baby girl you will
fall instantly in love when they place
your daughter in your arms a gift to
your family in so many ways as she helps
your heart heal her joyful spirit will
be a burst of sunshine in your lives
there's a fire starting in my heart
reaching a fever pitch it's bringing me
out the dark the years will pass quickly
and before you know it
Jacob sweet little brothers will be
grown men ready to graduate from high
school you are just so proud of these
boys and all that they have overcome but
this season of life will be bittersweet
because even if the world sees them as
twins they will forever be triplets in
your heart
remember your life is going to be filled
with the greatest joys and the deepest
heartaches but you will survive that
ache in your heart will always be there
Heather but it will make you stronger
you will hug a little tighter cry a
little easier and smile a little bigger
because of it and you will share Jacobs
story your faith and your grief in hopes
of helping others love big and hang on
to hope you can do it only Heather can
you do it you did it yeah boy I didn't
know where the story was going and it
took us on such a roller coaster what a
beautiful tribute to Jacob beautiful
woman so lovely that they have a baby
daughter
thank you very much Heather our book
note to self inspiring words from
inspiring people is available now it's
published by Simon & Schuster which is a
division of CBS we'll be right back